we're in a strange time with the media
where there's the mainstream media that
nobody seems to trust and now there's
the online media which is exploding and
it seems that nobody knows who to trust
anymore how do you decide who you trust
well my trust comes from experience
which is a great way to do it so I trust
I trust in the main the CBS's the NBC's
the ABCs I trust CNN I worked at CNN for
25 years I don't buy these stories of
plots at networks or I don't trust Fox I
don't trust MSNBC I don't regard them as
really news networks but they're more
preaching to choir network yeah so you
think there's a distinct difference
between the cable news guys and and the
traditional now absolutely CNN does try
to report fairly CNN is in a difficult
position because there's so much today
is so boxed off mm-hmm so they've got
Fox on the right and MSNBC on the left
and CNN straddles it so they're telling
a lot of documentaries I don't know
where they are
yeah you know what I respect them yeah
the main still trust the ministry maybe
my think though that a lot like tea
parties in the light have made you try
to distrust the mainstream media but I
have never seen in I've been in the
business 58 years yeah telling us the
people come over to me they tell me CNN
hates Israel or this cuz I have never
been in a meeting where someone said
let's go get somebody right let's angle
the story this way let's twist it I have
never seen that so at the end of the day
is it really just about what people will
watch more than an agenda because that's
what I see all the time people comment
especially online you get a lot of the
conspiracy people and they say this one
has this agenda or this one's owned by
this one or that but to me it always
comes down to what people will watch and
click so if there's a riot they're going
to cover a riot more than they would be
inclined to cover a rally for peace
right because it's just it's just what
people will turn on well news is well
first
I never had an agenda I never went on
the air to hurt someone or to boost
someone I just try to ask good questions
and listen to you're not boosting me
right now no I
well you're interviewing me oh so I
forgot we are date I've never I never
had an agenda I trust I trust them
you're I said I know print maybe is in
trouble
I trust the New York Times I think it's
the greatest newspaper I've ever read
and every day gets better and I've never
seen a paper that introduces me and
opens up doors to me better than the New
York Times and The New York Times
frankly and some cases the Washington
Post's the LA Times but mainly the New
York eyes television networks follow the
New York Times is based a lot of what
they cover yeah is what the New York
Times is showing them what to cover sure
great respect for the New York Times the
cable news part of it this
hyper-partisan thing that we see all the
time where Fox is obviously to the right
some people say they're not even to the
right they're just a sort of offshoot of
the Republican Party MSNBC is giving you
Democrat talking points CNN as you said
somewhere in between what do you make of
this idea that we're it's constantly -
people screaming at each other well it's
not my kind of broadcasting yeah the
problem with those shows to me I don't
learn anything yes you know to me when I
watch a show I want to know more than I
knew before I watch the show in these
screaming shows I see screaming but I
don't know more I don't see many good
interviewers yeah I see the host on if
you turn on a TV show on a regular basis
and the host is on more than the guests
yeah that's a bad show yeah in my face
and yet people seem to want screaming
what's dead like you mentioned if
there's a riot in the streets and a
peaceful protest you're gonna cover the
riot for example I'll tell you a
newscast that wouldn't do well good
evening ladies and gentlemen every
school in America today experienced no
problem there were no guns at any school
today and there were no hit-and-run
accidents in major cities yeah you're
tuning off you're not gonna watch this
right
whose is that which is not the ordinary
yeah so then wrapping up this topic how
do you feel about being you're sort of
you obviously came from the mainstream
and what you do now you're still talking
to mainstream people but it's in the
digital space how do you like being in
this sort of next to me I'm doing what
I've always done I since 1957 when I
broke in I've asked questions listened
to answers try to follow up I'm being
distributed differently
I was distributed first on a local
session yeah then I had a national radio
show
then satellites and then those CNN it
was worldwide and now now the Internet
but I'm doing the same thing there's
this what we're doing now yeah could
have been a radio show in 1935 yeah one
day we're gonna be doing this on
snapchat that'll be it maybe two seconds
long